>>> SO A GLIMMER OF HOPE FOR THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS CHAIR SAYING
DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING REALLY
CLOSE ON GETTING TO A FINAL DEAL
ON THE BROAD ECONOMIC SPENDING
BILL.
THE PROGRESSIVE WING OF THE
PARTY HAS BEEN IN A STANDOFF
WITH SENATORS JOE MANSION AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA WITH A $1.2
TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
MANY PROGRESSIVES SAYING THEY
WANT BOTH TO PASS SIMULTANEOUSLY
WHILE MANSION AND CINEMA SAID
THEY DON'T SUPPORT THE $3.5
TRILLION PRICE TAG OF THE LARGER
SPENDING BILL.
SO JOINING ME NOW IS DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN AND WHIP OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS AND THAT IS
ILHAN OMAR.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME, DON.
>> SO YOU WERE AT TONIGHT'S
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS MEETING AND
HOLDING SPEAKER PELOSI'S HAND AS
YOU CAME OUT BUT THE STAKES HERE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
BIDEN'S ENTIRE DOMESTIC AGENDA
IS ON THE LINE.
WHERE DO YOU STAND AFTER THIS
MEETING?
>> WELL, WE ARE REALLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT FIGHTING FOR
THE BIDEN AGENDA TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE HOUSE AND IN
THE SENATE AND FOR US TO SEND
THESE TWO BILLS IN TANDEM TO HIS
DESK.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO
FULFILL THEIR PROMISE.
THIS IS A PROMISE THAT THE
PRESIDENT MADE TO THEM ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IT IS THE PROMISE THAT WE, WHEN
WE WERE CAMPAIGNING MADE AND
THIS IS OUR ONCE IN A LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY TO DELIVER ON THAT.
WE HAVE ABOUT 12 MEMBERS IN THE
HOUSE, IN THE SENATE, ON THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WHO ARE, YOU
KNOW, AN OBSTACLE TO GETTING
THIS DONE.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THE
PUBLIC BELIEVE THAT THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS IS BLOCKING
THESE BILLS FROM PASSING.
IT THE OPPOSITE.
IF WE DON'T PASS THESE BILLS,
THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA WILL NOT
PASS SO WE'RE CONSISTENT IN
HAVING THE PRESIDENT'S BACK AND
SUPPORTING THE WHOLE AGENDA.
WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING
THAT IT TAKES TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS DONE.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU AS I
MENTIONED, THE PROGRESSIVE CARE
SAYING SHE BELIEVES LAWMAKERS
ARE GETTING CLOSE TO A FINAL
DEAL ON THE LARGER SPENDING
DEAL.
YOU TOLD MANU RAJU YOU NEED MADE
CLEAR, DO YOU KNOW WHERE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH, WE ARE REALLY GETTING
CLOSE.
THEY HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE FEW SENATORS HOLDING UP
PROGRESS, OUR CHAIRWOMAN HAD A
PHONE CALL AND A CONVERSATION
WITH KRYSTEN SINEMA AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE CLOSELY
MONITORING THE WORK THAT THE
SPEAKER, THAT THE MAJORITY
LEADER AND WHITE HOUSE IS DOING
IN BRINGING PROGRESS AND
BRINGING PROGRESS ON THESE
BILLS.
WHAT WE ARE WAITING FOR IS WHAT
IS IT THAT THEY ARE INTERESTED
IN SEEING CHANGED SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THIS LEGISLATION FORWARD?
>> YEAH.
SO WHAT ARE YOU WILLING TO
COMPROMISE ON AND I'M DOING
TO -- HOW MUCH LOWER THAN 3 $.5
TRILLION AND SO ON.
WHAT ARE YOU WILLING TO
COMPROMISE ON?
>> WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO IS
TO DELIVER ON
CONSTITUENTS IN REGARDS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DELIVER ON
DRUG PRICING AND CHILD CARE AND
TO DELIVER ON FAIR TAXATION.
HOW FAR THEY ARE WILLING TO GO
ON THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ON.
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT QUITE A
LOT IN OUR CAUCUS AND WITH THE
SENATORS JUST HOW MUCH OF A
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AND
INVESTMENT WE WANT TO MAKE IN
THESE AREAS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WAIT TO HEAR
WHAT KIND OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
AND INVESTMENTS THEY'RE WILLING
TO MAKE IN THEIR CONSTITUENT'S
LIVES BECAUSE WE'RE READY TO DO
EVERYTHING IT TAKES SO THE
PEOPLE CAN FEEL THE CHANGES IN
THEIR LIVES.
>> YOU'VE WRITTEN WITH A COUPLE
COLLEAGUES, CONGRESSWOMAN JIE
PAUL AND KATIE PORTER AND YOU
SAID YOU WRITE YOU'LL PUT YOUR
VOTES ON THE LINE AND ONLY VOTE
FOR THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ONLY AFTER
THE BUILD BACK BETTER BILL IS
PASSED.
IF AN AGREEMENT IS CLOSE AND YOU
GET ASSURANCES FROM MANSION AND
CINEMA, DOES THAT CHANGE
ANYTHING FOR YOU?
>> SO A FRAME WORK AND POLICIES
NEED TO BE AGREED WITHIN THAT
FRAME WORK IN ORDER FOR THERE TO
BE ANY PROGRESS.
WE NEED IN THE HOUSE WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR IS THAT OUR, YOU
KNOW, NOW THAT OUR BILL IS DONE
IN THE HOUSE, IT'S WRITTEN, WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE A
MANAGER'S AMENDMENT FOR ANY
CHANGES THEY WANT TO MAKE AND WE
WANT TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM.
HOW MUCH ARE THEY WILLING TO
INVEST IN REGARDS TO LOWERING
COST FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES?
WHETHER THEY ARE WILLING TO
REDUCE CHILD CARE COSTS BURDENS
FOR SO MANY AMERICANS AND
WHETHER THEY BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING IN COMMUNITY
AND TRADE SCHOOL.
THESE ARE STILL QUESTIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ANSWERED BY THESE
SENATORS AND SOME OF OUR HOUSE
COLLEAGUES.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR CAUCUS
STANDS UNITED TO DELIVER THE
AGENDA OF THE PRESIDENT AND, YOU
KNOW, DON, IF YOU REMEMBER IT'S
BEEN MONTHS THAT THIS DEAL HAS
BEEN AGREED UPON AS SENATOR
BERNIE SANDERS HAS SAID OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE BY
-- BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION WOULD
NOT HAVE PASSED WITH HIS SUPPORT
AND SUPPORT OF SO MANY OTHER
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE IF AN
AGREEMENT WASN'T REACHED THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO PASS THESE TWO
BILLS TOGETHER IN ORDER TO
FULFILL THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
NOW THAT THEY ARE GETTING ON
THAT PROMISE AND THAT DEAL, WE
HAVE TO HOLD THE LINE AND WE
HAVE TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR BREAKING THE DEAL THAT THEY
MADE WITH US.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, WE KNOW IT'S A
VERY BUSY TIME AND QUITE A TENSE
TIME BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA ON THE LINE
AND THE THINGS THAT HE PROMISED
YOU ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL ON THE
LINE.
WE APPRECIATE